zombie trains creepy castles and the
worst thing you can say to French
zombies
The Walking Dead Daryl Dixon continues
with another revelatory episode as our
team ushers what could be the second
coming of Christ throughout the French
Countryside in this video we take a deep
dive into the episode check out a bunch
of hidden details and make sure to stick
around till the end of the video where I
go over clues in the trailers to see
what could be happening next but before
we begin take a moment to like And
subscribe so I can afford my zombie
apocalypse bunker episode 2 starts
roughly 11 years ago before the start of
the zombie virus Isabelle the nun we met
in episode 1 is far from the holy figure
we've made her out to be she dances with
multiple men does drugs and Steals and
when we see her look into her purse
she's stolen this same credit card as
the man who bought her a drink and the
watch from the man who gave her cocaine
we can also make out her wrist scars
which in episode 1 implied she attempted
suicide one of the things I enjoyed
about this episode is that it didn't
give away all her backstory there's
still some mystery of how she got into
this place in life who this lover is and
how the outbreak began there's this
great shot where she looks at her
reflection in the mirror almost as if to
say is this the life I've chosen for
myself while overlooking the Eiffel
Tower things start to go awry screams
can be heard and a man is hit by a car
but it's not until she hits Saint George
station that we get our first real
glimpse of the zombie attack St George
also happens to be a famous Saint who
was martyred rather than recanting his
Christian faith interesting since
Isabelle will devote her life to
Christianity in my episode 1 video which
I'll leave a link to in the description
below I went into detail on how the
outbreak may have originated in France
so what we're seeing here could be
ground zero for the virus that will
eventually take over the world it would
explain how no one really knows what's
going on this is where we meet Quinn who
saves Isabelle from her first zombie up
close encounter now I have a lot of
questions about this guy how did he know
where she was what exactly is is their
relationship with one another they can't
be too deeply in love if she's out on
the town dancing with strange men and
later she'll steal his keys to leave him
the fact he came out of the blue wearing
a suit and black car makes me think a
some sort of chauffeur or B someone
there to protect Isabelle could Isabel
be somehow linked to the creation of the
virus obviously there is something in
Isabel's past that has led her to take
drugs attempt suicide and engage in
Risky behavior and I hope as The Story
Goes On we'll find out more back in
present day Daryl Isabel Sylvie and
Laurent continue their Journey to the
encampment up north the big question
seems to be whether they take this safe
route which is longer or the fast route
which is more dangerous in the past we
meet Isabel's pregnant sister Lily the
name Lily means Purity and innocence not
a bad name if you're the mother of the
second coming of Christ we never find
any true information about Ronald's
father and whether or not the writers
will lean into Immaculate Conception
like the Virgin Mary later tells the
kids at the preschool that his father
was falsely imprisoned and fought with
the French Legion against the hungry
ones but the other kids pick up that
this was likely a lie and that's one of
the big themes of this episode lying
Isabelle lies to them all about their
donkey as their leaks when he wanders
off she says he's safe and has gone to
eat apples but it later found out that
donkey is dead Asterix also happens to
be the name of a popular French cartoon
character the wall is also lied to about
his father and just how special he is
they haven't told him they think he's
the second coming of Christ just that
he's special Daryl lies to Lou about
Madame dua's medicine Lou lies to the
children about some of them going
missing and Isabelle lies about Daryl
being a priest it's just lies all around
more of Isabelle's shady past is
revealed when we see her retrieving a
hidden box underneath the fireplace
filled with cash and jewelry it looks
like she was saving up for something and
didn't want any of this money in the
bank here we see a young girl who talked
talks about her father having gone
missing if you stick around to the end
of the video in my trailer section you
might just find this isn't the last time
we see her as Daryl and the Gang let
Asterix go Daryl wonders why Isabelle
doesn't tell Laurel the truth that the
donkey is likely dead but she responds
you don't have children do you Daryl is
commonly perceived as a lone wolf
character and although he's never had
children of his own became like a
surrogate father to Judith and RJ this
conversation however is short-lived as
the gang is attacked by a group of teens
who take them to a preschool that has
been turned into an orphanage here A
Girl by the name of Lou is in charge
after Madame Dubois has taken to illness
six months prior when Isabelle says
they're religious people Lou makes them
recite Saint Joseph's prayer as a sort
of test an interesting choice since
Joseph was the father of Jesus this
prayer is all about asking Joseph for
strength and protection so if Laurent is
the second coming and Daryl becomes this
father-like figure to him just like
Joseph was Jesus you can start to see
the significance of this prayer
currently there are 18 children here who
hunt and grow food to survive however a
local Raider they call La talesque named
after a French mythological dragon has
hoarded all the supplies and cooped
himself up in a nearby castle with their
donkey eaten Daryl thinks this might be
a good place to find a replacement and
makes a deal with Lou show him where the
castle is and he'll get medicine that
can save Madame duois of course this is
a lie he knows Dubois is far gone and no
medicine will save her he just wants
that ass I mean donkey to get back on
his way after watching an episode of
Mork and Mindy a show about an outsider
living in a strange world just like
Daryl adjust to France we can see in his
face how his decision to lie affects him
later Daryl will end up getting those
medical supplies even though they'll do
no good it's decisions like these that
really show how nuanced his character is
Mork and Mindy also happens to be the
show Daryl and his brother Merle who you
may remember from season one watched his
kids to make their lives feel a little
bit better father Daryl's is arguably
one of the worst Graces ever stating
that maybe Humanity deserved what they
got because of how they treated one
another we know from episode 1 that
Daryl is not a religious man now could
the show be building up to a potential
love interest between Daryl and Isabel
in episode 1 she bathed him while he was
naked and now we have them sleeping in
the same bed even after Daryl offered to
sleep on the floor Isabelle laments how
the kids will never know a life before
the outbreak but Daryl says you can't
miss what you never had in another
flashback Quinn tries to get rid of Lily
telling Isabel she needs a hospital and
the two of them must leave we never find
out where he intends to take her other
than it's quote somewhere secluded but
Isabel won't leave her sister and ends
up swiping his keys and taking off I
wonder if we'll see this guy again on
their travels he'd definitely be pissed
if he saw her again Lou knows that Daryl
isn't a priest but goes on with the
charade because he's promised to get
medicine he'll later lock her in a
nearby shed which I took to mean he did
because he didn't want to see her get
hurt Sylvian Isabelle struggle with how
they should deal with Laurel stating
that once they get up north all of them
will find their purpose back in time
Lily's pregnancy takes a dangerous turn
they find some paramedics but as luck
would have it they are Undead one taking
a big chomp out of Lily remember that
this is the start of the outbreak so
there really isn't any knowledge on how
the virus is transmitted so when Lily
and Isabelle arrive at St Bernadette's
they're welcomed even though Lily has
this bite mark Daryl makes his way over
a zombie-infested moat into the
courtyard of the castle and hears please
for help from one of the missing kids
this is elisan or Hedgehog in English
it's never stated why the man will come
to known as RJ kept him here but it
can't be good as Hedgehog provides
suppressing fire Daryl slips behind RJ
and holds him at gunpoint turns out he's
an American too an American who like
Daryl wants to get back home to his
family that is if he's even telling the
truth the man is obviously a little
crazy talking about putting toothpaste
on biscuits this guy must have been here
for a long time because Daryl has to
tell him that all of the United States
hasn't basically been decimated with RJ
tied up they make their way across the
moat when the cart's wheel slips off
throwing gas canisters below RJ uses
this opportunity to make a dash for the
gun prompting Daryl to fight for it and
the two falling into the zombie-infested
moat below I thought this scene was
pretty badass you have Daryl fighting
off zombies with a mace and RJ getting
eaten as his body hangs from the card
above luckily Daryl still has that rifle
which he uses to blow the gas canisters
allowing him enough time to be pulled up
by Lou and move but unfortunately for
move he's finally found the whereabouts
of his lost brother who has turned into
a zombie below Lou puts him out of his
misery with an arrow to the Head Daryl's
chewed out for locking Lu up and she
states that she hopes he learned his
lesson that he isn't better off by
himself and that's probably one of the
big things Daryl's character will have
to learn to throughout this season he
must turn away from his Lone Wolf
Tendencies and learn to trust others if
he's going to grow as a character back
at school Madame Dubois has passed away
Daryl offers to stab her in the head
before she turns but Lou Has the
strength to do it herself outside is a
makeshift Shrine to those they have lost
now with the addition of Madame Dubois
you'll notice the kids do this
[Music]
is the term used in Mork and Mindy for
goodbye until next week
doesn't want to go this is the first
time he's been around kids his age but
his journey must take precedence back at
the Abbey an injured kodung looks at the
aftermath of his battle with the nuns in
Father John's office he finds the map
giving him a starting off point to
search for the man who he thinks killed
his brother in our final flashback it's
revealed that Lily gives birth in the
Abbey but not before turning into a
zombie its father Jean who has to
perform an emergency C-section to save
the child who Isabelle takes as Jean
performs what looks to be an exorcism
this is not the event where Father John
Was Bitten as that happens after the law
has grown up remember it was father Jean
who the nun's credit for Laurel's polite
behavior and intelligence logon was
named after Saint Laurent Isabelle found
his statue in the Abbey he was a
martyred Saint who holds a griddle the
supposed instrument of his demise after
he was burned to death although how
exactly he died is still a point of
contention lurewalt has been called the
cure for Humanity being this second
coming of Christ but what if he's the
literal cure his mother carrying him
while turning into a zombie may have
given him special antibodies to protect
against turning into the undead I could
totally see him getting bitten later in
the series and not turning into one of
them and I don't consider this a spoiler
because it happens in the first episode
but it's kind of similar to what happens
to Ellie in The Last of Us now we get to
that point in the video where we take a
look at the season's trailers to look at
Clues as to what could happen next keep
in mind I won't be covering every shot
just the ones that pertain to new
information we got this episode with
kadun picking up the tape recorder at
the end of the episode it looks like he
brings it to Janae who we saw at the end
of episode 1 ordering her men to find
Daryl kodron will be put on the case
especially since he knows the route
they'll likely take episode 2 also
confirmed this season will have
flashbacks and the trailers show Daryl
on that tanker he escaped from so we'll
probably get a lot more insight into how
exactly Daryl wound up in Europe
remember this girl we met in Paris well
looks like she didn't fare too well here
she is in Zombie form with the same hair
braid and beaded necklace we kind of
already know this but Isabelle and Daryl
make it back to Paris here we have
Sylvie and their own captured by khadron
and his men we don't see Isabel or Daryl
here either they're off to the side or
somewhere else getting ready to save
them here's the cart making its way past
the pantheon in Paris fun fact Simone
Vale the name the preschool in episode 2
is named after is buried here you can
see this Banner reading foyer which
means flee now take a look at this guy
could this be Quinn Isabelle's lover she
ditched at the gas station it's hard to
get a look at him but let me know what
you think in the comments here's a
picture of Daryl alone outside mulsi
Michelle if he's alone here does this
mean he's finished his mission and left
Laurel in Isabel here meaning this is
the northern base we've heard so much
about all these questions I'm hoping
will be answered in the week to come but
now I turn it over to you what did you
think of the second episode I want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching
please make sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory
YT until next time remember until next
week
[Music]
foreign